you
[Music]
hi welcome to operating multi-tenant
kafka services for developers so this is
the agenda for the talk I'm gonna give
you a little intro about myself and
Heroku Heroku data I look at the
motivation behind building the
multi-tenant kafka service in general
take a look at our existing single
tenant Kafka compare that with
multi-tenancy what the multi-tenancy
implications are and then we'll go into
some of the configurations and changes
that we made and some of the tuning that
we did talk a little bit about testing
and then hopefully cover automation
which is kind of our thing and discuss
some of the limitations that were you
know necessary as a result of making a
multi-tenant service so I'm a Hemi D I'm
an engineer on the Heroku data team at
Salesforce her occur is a cloud platform
that enables companies to build
applications in a variety of languages
deploy on on our platform and actually
it helps them to run that scale it
monitor it Heroku data specifically is
the team at Heroku that provides the
data services on top of it and so we
provide Heroku Postgres or Redis and
cough cough course so a brief about
Kafka hopefully many of you are aware of
it already
Kafka itself is an Apache project it's a
distributed streaming platform it
provides the pub/sub model in calculon's
it's produce and consume you so you
produced the clock of the cluster and
you consume from it
it's a durable meshes message store so
on disk
it's a ordered commit lock and it's
highly available so you have multiple
brokers that can hold multiple replicas
of your data and so if a single broker
goes down you still have replicas and
it'll fail over and you you continue and
so what is Apache cough gone for ku
specifically so we provide a fully
managed service so it's a more of a
batteries included approach
it's opinionated in the sense that in
cases where there are multiple
configuration options we make a decision
based on what we feel is a safe or
productive default and we we provide
that out of the box it's configured for
best practices for most users and I put
a little asterisks because there's no
you know you can't make
one-size-fits-all there are bound to be
use cases that aren't really well suited
but we try to cover as many as possible
and try to get the the largest coverage
as possible
and so I want to talk a little bit about
the use cases for for caffeine in
general so why would you use Kafka and
not some other dates store or other
streaming service and so I'm going to
cover a couple of use cases and then
look at specific customers that were on
procure that used to work with Kafka
so one of the ones I'm looking posing a
monolithic app so in this case we're
taking a a big monolith and we're using
Kafka as a chance port medium or an
interconnect between the various
services or micro services to transport
information and events between them
another use case I'm going to cover is
process dating high-volume
real time date streams so you may have
something that is naturally a stream of
events so like currency information or
events coming from an IOT device or
whatever it is and you just have a a
torrent of data that you're collecting
from various sources you want to make
real-time decisions on those and the
third use case I'm going to cover is
providing real-time event-driven
architecture so this is pretty similar
to the second case but essentially you
have a number of disparate services that
are producing events and you're trying
to make decisions on some kind of
aggregate of that data so you have a
number of sources they're all telling
you different things and you wanna make
real-time decisions on what you should
be doing and so for the first case
decomposing the monolith I'm going to
talk a little bit about shift commerce
so you can actually read about it they
have a blog post on the Heroku blog that
talks about it and so they they
basically leveraged Heroku Kafka as a
path to gradual migration from a
monolith into micro service
so essentially what they did was they
introduced the ability for their
monolith to produce events into Kafka
and then gradually over time they
introduced more and more services that
consume those events and move the logic
out of the monolith into those new micro
services so for the second use case I
wanted to talk a little bit about coin
it's pronounced coin coin is a FinTech
company based out of Singapore and they
mostly deal with a cryptocurrency
exchanges and the mostly active in Japan
and so essentially they have a huge
torrent of pricing data for
cryptocurrencies coming from a number of
different exchanges and they aggregate
them and sort of make decisions in real
time on on what to do and how the prices
affect their decisions the last use case
I wanna cover is Caesars Entertainment
of you know casino fame and other things
and essentially they they use it to
ingest and aggregate a large amount of
customer data from lots and lots of
different sources and they use it to
make decisions on how best to provide
services or offers or deals to their
most prized VIP customers and so these
are like very different systems all
producing events they aggregate them
they process them they try to make
decisions on how best to serve their
customers so I wanna talk a little bit
the motivation why why bother building a
multi-tenant Kafka we already have a
relatively successful dedicated Kafka
product so these are some of the
motivations behind it some of the goals
right now our single tenant Kafka starts
at $1,500 for the for the base plan
which is the standard zero and so with
that you get three brokers and five
zookeepers which is kind of a pretty
standard for our our zookeeper topology
and a thousand five hundred is could be
relatively reasonable for you but we
want to lower that barrier we want to
make it much easier to access and so you
know if you're working in development
you haven't really finished your product
yet that's that might be too high a
barrier-free and so you know targeting
development testing low volume
production we want to introduce
something that's a little bit more
accessible and so our multi-tenant plans
right now start at $100 so it's that's
quite a substantial reduction
so here's the blogpost when we announced
it
it's September 14 2017 so we've had
multi-tenant Kafka for quite a while so
I want to talk a little bit about the
differences single tenant versus multi
tenant and what it looks like
so single tenant is pretty obvious we
have one customer or one tenant that has
access to the entire cluster and so your
security boundaries or your resource
boundaries are really outside of the
cluster everything in the cluster is
yours and so this is really what it
looks like when you talk Kafka you're
really dealing with topics so all the
topics are owned by single customer you
don't really need to worry about any
isolation at that level with
multi-tenancy it kind of looks like this
and so we have a large number of
customers all residing on a single
traffic cluster and so that introduces a
whole range of new sort of issues that
you need to tackle I know this is kind
of a wall of text but I'm gonna break
down and talk about each one separately
so you know we talk about resource
isolation we talk about parity compare
compatibility and costs related to it so
I'm going to focus on resource isolation
first and talk about security
implications performance implications
and safety so when I talk about security
what I really mean is a tenant should
not be able to access on others another
tenants data this is kind of table
stakes for multi-tenancy it would be
kind of a disaster if we put everyone on
the same cluster and everyone could read
everyone else's data so you know the
priority the main thing is this did not
happen you shouldn't be able to read
other people's data with Kafka because
we actually talk about topics all the
time this is really what we mean user a
shouldn't be able to read user B's
topics and so how do we how do we do
that Kafka itself has native support for
access control lists Oracle's and so
it's a somewhat relatively new feature
in Kafka life but essentially what
allows you to do is specify user a can
carry out action be on resource C so
user a can
read or describe or write topic messages
which is owned by user a but there's no
explicit Akal for allowing it to read
anything of topic B or user B so it
can't so the other thing we do is name
spacing so this is something that's
somewhat unique to us and that we
namespace resources per tenant so when
you create a new multi tenant Kafka
add-on on Heroku we automatically
generate a name in this case wall - five
eight seven seven nine so we pick a
river - some numbers and that becomes a
prefix for all of your resources so you
create the topic messages you get wall -
whatever it is thought messages that
also applies to the consumer groups and
that's actually what we applied the
Ackles to so any topic that begins with
wabash whatever is owned by tenant a
anything that has a different prefixes
on by another donor so the second aspect
of that I was looking to his performance
and what I mean here is really this
attendance should not adversely affect
another tenants performance so this is
typically what we refer to as the noisy
neighbor so you're sharing a cluster
with someone they're super active
they're absolutely hammering their
broker and your performance goes down
the toilet as a result of it so
obviously that sucks for everyone except
for the person who's abusing the
resources and so we want to prevent that
and so in the case of Kafka Kafka has
support for quotas so that's super cool
it's really useful it allows you to
specify a produce quota and a consume
quota in terms of bytes per second and
so we say you know ten and a can have
256 kilobytes per second produce and one
megabyte per second consume and calf get
itself enforces that I'll talk a little
bit later about the way that's enforced
because it's kind of interesting the
third part of resource isolation is
safety and so here what I actually mean
is a tenant should not jeopardize the
stability of the cluster so we don't
want the we don't want a single tenant
who does something unusual or has a
misbehaving client to take down the
cluster for everyone else
and so in order to to you know prevent
that we apply limits and so we can apply
limits to topics and by here by that I
mean the number of topics and by
association the number of partitions
which is really the thing that scales on
Kafka the number of consumer groups
storage and throughput I want to talk a
little bit more about storage because
it's kind of interesting kefka's concept
of storage is more of a transient thing
messages live on the Kefka cluster for a
certain amount of time they don't live
there forever it's not a a you know
source of truth for your data forever
and so thinking of it in terms of static
storage is is a little bit strange so
instead we think of it as capacity and
this is a term that we use in all of our
documentation and essentially that's a
function of message throughput
multiplied by the retention on all those
messages multiplied by the replication
so if I do 100 messages per second and I
have a 1-day retention and I want three
replicas of it and you multiply that all
together and that's actually the total
amount of storage using across the
cluster and then there's the the
throughput itself which I kind of
covered with quotas and so imposing
these limits is it's cool some of them
are natively supported within Kafka so
you can specify quotas or ackles to do
certain things and storage is something
that you know we cover with the capacity
which is this slightly more complicated
function but we need to be able to
monitor it we actually need to be able
to look at this and say you know are
these limits being exceeded are they
being you know adhered to in particular
with storage the way it works in our
case is that we allow you to grow the
storage on the cluster so you spin up a
cluster we give you 100 gigabytes of
storage you start putting data into it
and you get close to the hundred
gigabytes we actually grow it
automatically for you so we don't take
down your cluster because you hit your
limit we have a pretty generous grace
sort of area where we will you know
increase the storage and let you
continue but that's great for the
customer but we aren't really doing you
any favors by allowing you to grow
unbounded so we actually have to monitor
it and so we check occasionally see you
know are you still within the limits are
you nearing a dangerous limit and so
monitoring is kind of key to that but
then more so than just monitoring is
actually being able to enforce limits so
some of them are nice because they're
natively supported in Kafka but in the
case of storage if our automation
automatically grows the volumes then you
could just keep growing forever and
eventually the cluster will topple over
and so we actually have to have a
mechanism for enforcing it so in the
case of Kafka multi-tenant will send you
an email saying hey you've exceeded your
storage by 150 percent
you should probably slow it down or
upgrade your plan and if you keep going
faster then we impose an additional more
aggressive throttling to kind of slow
your your growth and get you back under
the limit and then if you just fly past
there for an extended period of time
we actually block access to try to let
it clear out and then we'll enable it
again so another area of multi-tenancy
which is kind of specific to
multi-tenancy is parity and so here
we're talking about feature parity as
well as behavior parity and so I say
parity but what I really mean is for the
service to be useful it needs to behave
like a normal cluster there's no point
in us giving you something that looks
and behaves in a way that's totally
unlike Kafka because you could code
against it and you could deploy your
application against it and it works fine
but then you switch to a regular Kefka
and everything breaks and it just
doesn't do what you think it does and so
I don't dress this we actually give you
access to what is effectively a standard
Kafka cluster it looks very much like
our dedicated clusters it's the same
number of brokers it's the same number
of zookeeper nodes it behaves in exactly
the same way and so one of these things
one of the the things that we thought
about is that we could have gone with a
single broker single zookeeper option
and that would have been pretty cost
effective and we could do it quite
easily but then the customer will be
developing against something that's not
really representative of real life Uwe
would deploy a production catholic
cluster with one broker and one
zookeeper and so you won't have exposure
to things like rolling restarts or when
topics failover and all that stuff so
your application my work fine with only
one but then once you switch to a real
cluster which has eight brokers and
they start failing over and things start
moving around the application breaks so
we actually give you access to something
that represents what a real production
cluster would look like so if you do
move then your application is ready for
it so there are some limitations we have
to make some compromises in order to
provide these you know the level of
safety that I mentioned earlier so as
much as possible we try to keep it
standard but there's there's going to be
some some things that we have to change
compatibility is the next thing I want
to talk about in this case what I really
mean is the service needs to support
standard clients no vendor lock-in so
that's absolutely a core part of
pirozhkis belief and we only use open
source Apache Kafka it's not a custom
fork there's no weird custom code
required on the client side there's
nothing strange that we we do in order
to enable this you use absolutely
standard clients and whatever your
favorite languages and you can connect
to it and you use it that's kind of a
big thing for us and it applies to all
of our data services really so the last
implication I want to talk about is
costs and specifically costs of
resources and operational costs so what
does it cost to run for the things that
we run like VMs and instances plus what
does it cost us to actually operate it
and so here I'm talking about the
service needs to be financially feasible
and in this case I'm actually talking
about our costs not so much the cost for
the customer although they're obviously
related so here the things that go into
the resource costs will be packing
density
how many tenants do we pack on this
cluster and conversely but somewhere
related is the utilization of that
cluster like how well utilized is it the
more utilized it is the more efficiently
we're spending our money on these
resources but with that comes a few sort
of interesting cases where we have
consciously made a decision to take a
hit on our part in order to provide
certain functionality
and so when we look at cluster size we
have some options we could have one
massive cluster with hundreds of brokers
in fact all of the tenants onto there or
we could have very very small clusters
like one broker one zookeeper and so
there's some decisions there where there
are implications related to the way it
performs the way a failover is work
there is a sweet spot for a cluster size
and we've actually already done this
process we've looked into this we did
all the testing when we looked at the
single dedicated plans and we settled on
you know a maximum of eight brokers and
five zookeepers because of the way it
behaves and so we kind of favor that we
also kind of insisted pretty early on
that we don't over provision and so when
we tell a customer you're signing up for
a particular plan we make sure that they
have all those resources and so we don't
over provision it in any way so again if
we say we're gonna pack 20 customers
onto a cluster and they all join on with
the lowest plan then our utilization is
pretty low and so that sucks from a
resource cost but it's great from the
customer point of view because now they
have the resources that they expected
also we wanted to provide seamless
upgrading so the idea is a customer can
join on with the lowest plan and they
should be able to upgrade to the next
lineup or the biggest plan that we have
for a multi-tenant without any
disruption and so unfortunately when it
comes to Kafka there is no easy way to
actually migrate offsets so if you move
from one class to the other the offsets
aren't really translatable in that sense
so in order to get around this we have
to assume the worst case or the best
case depending on your perspective that
every customer could potentially upgrade
to the biggest plan and so inherently
our utilization is pretty low when it
comes to operational costs this is kind
of an area that we want to focus on
because this is the amount of man-hours
that we sink into it and we're not a
huge team so this kind of makes a big
difference for us so we want to minimize
the operational burden and minimize the
impact or the blast radius of particular
issues so again going back to the
cluster size if we had one massive
cluster with 100 brokers and there was a
cluster wide issue then that could
potentially affect hundreds or thousands
of customers and so again we fall back
into the Suites
of saying you know if we have clusters
that are eat brokers and we've hack 2530
tenants onto it we can kind of minimize
the blast radius into a particular area
and minimizing operational costs again
if we match the single tenant clusters
and the topology then we can actually
share the learnings between them so all
of the gaining all the gained knowledge
and experience from operating a fleet of
three and eight broker clusters we
actually map immediately and so we find
a bug in one sort of topology or one
behavior one performance tuning that
works on one we can immediately map it
over to the next to the multi tenant
without really any loss some of the
other ways that we kind of reduce the
operational burden for us is that we we
pick safe default so it's possible to to
kind of put yourself in a unfortunate
situation by picking settings that are
not ideal so if you think about the
situation where you create a topic and
you set replication to one which was the
default in lots of clusters so the
customer creates a topic and they start
writing things to it and we fail over
that broker well what happened to the
data
it only resided on one and so now it's
gone forever that sucks for the customer
and maybe they weren't aware of it or
maybe they assumed that you know as sane
default was used so we actually enforce
that so we pick those safety faults both
to provide a better user experience also
to reduce reduce the operational burden
for us as I mentioned we pick similar
clusters to our dedicated so we can
share those learnings and we do a ton of
automation automation I wrote it's kind
of our thing that's like the epic
understatement we're a very small team
and we manage millions of dates or data
bases and data services millions without
exaggeration that's actually what we do
and we did a ton of testing we did a
huge amount of testing on the
multi-tenant topologies different size
kapha clusters different configurations
different releases all sorts of stuff in
order to arrive a configuration that we
think is is pretty sound and pretty
solid and that all feeds back into
reducing operational cost for us
so I want to talk a little bit about
configuration and tuning and sort of
talk a little bit about some of the
changes that we made some of the
configurations that we did in order to
achieve what we aimed to do in and what
we actually have running in our
multi-tenant fleet so recover partitions
the number of partitions what they look
like
quotas how those work topics and
consumer groups specifically how they're
created and the idea of guardrails and
so this is something that we we kind of
implement to make it better for
customers to run on on Heroku so
partitions we have a we have tested and
we we set a very very large number of
partitions for Kafka for the most part
like the industry average is maybe one
or two thousand partitions per broker
that's kind of like the rule of thumb we
are at close to six thousand and it's
unusually high but this is kind of the
trade-off that we make for being able to
pack so many tenants and give them the
freedom to create the number of topics
that they they want or they need and the
number of partitions per topic that they
need in order to support a large number
of partitions we actually have to tune
the max number of file descriptors and
so all of our clusters run at 500
thousand which again is is pretty
atypical it's unusually high for for
brokers of the size but again this is
you know through our testing our
extensive testing we've arrived at this
number and we know it's it's a safe
number for these clusters and similarly
we've increased the max memory map count
to your 500 thousand if you look at most
Kafka Doc's they'll tell you increase it
but to what is kind of up in the air and
it really depends on your usage I want
to cover quotas a little bit because
there's kind of a unusual implementation
and so tip 13 introduced to kotas and
0.9 and something that's kind of
counterintuitive both the enforcement
and the way it's implemented in the
first place is that quotas are actually
implemented per broker and so
if you think about this if I set a 1
megabyte per second produced quota on
Kafka using the CLI commands what I'm
actually getting is 1 megabyte per
broker so then if I think oh I've given
my customer 8 megabytes and then I
double the size of my cluster I've
actually given them now 16 megabytes
it's not really calculated across the
cluster and if you look at the
documentation they basically say it's
it's easier to implement it this way and
so our quotas are the the quote is
documented are actually the the cluster
wide aggregate the enforcement for
produce quotas is super counterintuitive
and actually caught us out a few times
but the way it works is that when you
produce 2 Kafka it sends you back a
response saying ok I got it
it's been act it's been written when the
quote is in effect and you've exceeded
your quota it actually does all the work
you know it accepts your message it
writes it to the commit log it sends it
off to all the brokers that are
replicating but then it just waits to
respond to you and so the idea is this
introduces backwards compatibility so
even if your client doesn't know
anything about quotas it should if it's
a well behaved client wait for the ACK
before it tries to produce more in
reality many Catholic clients are not
well written or don't really adhere to
this behavior and they'll just keep
throwing more data at it and the Kafka
broker will happily accept it so just
keep accepting as much data as you send
it and just won't respond to you but if
your client doesn't care it will just
keep continuing and so you end up with
this case where it's sort of like the
honored based implementation of quotas
it's like you really shouldn't send me
anything and then you just do
and there's accepts it this actually led
to another issue that we uncovered but
I'll cover that a little bit so yeah if
you are using Kafka and you are using
produce quotas that's something to to
keep in mind
with topics and consumer groups this is
kind of an unfortunate side effect of of
us you know unfortunate necessity and
the way we implemented multi-tenancy and
that there is no way in in Kafka even
with with ackles to specify a numeric
limit to the number of topics so we
can't say user a can create 40 topics
and 200 partitions the Ackles don't have
that kind of granularity so in order for
us to impose those limits instead we
actually split the control plane from
Kafka and Heroku so the idea is we
remove the ability to create topics
dynamically through the admin API and
instead we force the customer to go
through the Heroku API in order to
create these topics and so that gives us
a the gateway the point the entry point
in order to enforce these limits so for
the most part that's not really an issue
most of our users wish that they could
dynamically create topics and consumer
groups but in reality it's not really a
blocker in most cases so last sort of a
major topic in configuration but I want
to cover is guardrails and so the idea
here is to limit potential bad usage so
customers may use clients that are
poorly written because their language
doesn't have like a great supported
client or they may miss configure the
client in a way that introduces bad
behavior that could cause instability or
other performance issues and so this is
quote which I've heard many times in
Heroku but I'm actually not sure who
said it initially but essentially its
customers don't make mistakes we make
bad tools and the idea is if we give the
opportunity for a customer to make a
mistake and behave badly then it's
actually on us like we shouldn't have
let them do that and so wherever
possible we try to build in these
guardrails we try to put things in place
to prevent customers from from making
mistakes essentially and so some of the
configurations that we we have are on
the Heroku data plane side that we
actually enforce is minimum retention
time this is something that customers
often
ask about because it seems kind of weird
like why are you telling me that I
should keep data around for at least
this long it seems kind of like a
bizarre thing for us to enforce but
through our testing and if you look
through the mailing lists
anything less introduces a lot of turn
on the broker
so you're basically wasting cycles
wasting i UPS throwing out data that you
could be doing something productive with
and so we found that 24 hours is kind of
the sweet spot most people most
customers ask us like why is it why is
that the minimum but it's it's almost
never an issue we have a max retention
time for a multi-tenant plan of seven
days we have a default replication
factor of three a minimum replication
factor of three and a maximum replica
replication factor of three so it should
tell you that really you should have a
replication of three we don't allow
anything else and this is kind of one of
the more significant guardrails that we
have in place and the some of the
defaults in Kafka would not necessarily
have three he would create a topic and
it just gives you one replication and
weird things start happening and so we
strictly force in for three within Kafka
itself we've also changed the defaults
again to make them a little bit more
sane more safe and so the default number
of partitions we set is eight
the default for Kafka itself is one and
so with one you aren't gaining any of
the benefits of scale that will only
reside on a single broker and your
performance will be basically pinned to
a single broker's worth of throughput
and if you remember what I mentioned
about quotas essentially quotas are
enforced per broker so if you create a
one partition topic and your quota is
128k the maximum throughput you'll ever
get through it is 128k because it's all
going through one broker so we defaults
to the same number of brokers in the
cluster again replication three we're
pretty serious about it
so if you missed it the first time we're
gonna get it the second time it's gonna
be three minions Inc replicas if you're
not familiar with how this works is
essentially on the Kafka broker you can
specify the number of
confirmed rights from replicas before
you write back to the client and you say
I have received this message previous
releases of Kafka had it set to one and
so it or I think it was may have been
zero actually so just the receiving
broker says I have got this message and
then the client would think great I've
written it I should continue with my
life and then that broker dies and
you've lost all your messages and so
it's kind of confusing and
counterintuitive
so our default is set to two and most
recent versions of Kafka actually have
it to two as well a little bit about
monitoring at Heroku we use a custom
monitoring tool it's called Observatory
it's pretty awesome
it's agentless and the sense that one of
the core beliefs of Heroku data and for
its monitoring is that all monitoring
should be done from the outside in so we
don't actually deploy anything in the
brokers or on the containers or on the
servers themselves what that gives us is
this amazing power where you know
through support or through on-call we
discover oh actually there's this thing
there's this metric that we should be
monitoring and we aren't so we basically
teach our monitoring tool how to look at
that thing and now that metric is being
exposed across every single instance in
our fleet so we push some code and now a
million databases are now telling us
something new it's it's pretty
spectacular it's like one of the best
things that we've come up with I think
jmx is pretty great and so jmx is purely
a java thing which is not great but
Kafka itself exposes a ton of metrics
about every aspect everything you
possibly want from your Kafka broker JMX
can tell you but it's java only which
sucks Jolokia is a HTTP proxy for jmx
and so when we deploy Kafka we deployed
your locator with it and that basically
allows us to reap the benefits of JMX
without having to run java on our
control plane itself or the monitoring
actually so that's pretty fantastic and
I highly recommend it
so testing I mentioned we did a ton of
testing this was was pretty grueling we
tested a ridiculous number of
permutations a number of partitions
maximum partitions
what kind of throughput should we
provide for each tenant what's the
maximum that we can get looking at
different message sizes Kafka behaves
very differently if you send lots of
very small messages or very large
messages what about common operations so
we have a huge number of partitions
we're hammering it with a million large
messages and then we decide to take one
of the brokers out does it survive that
so there were some topologies we were
like yes this is the one it's perfect
everything works fine and then someone
says well let's do a rolling restart and
then it just cascades and everything
dies immediately so yeah we actually
looked through all these failure
scenarios you know we swap out a broker
we replace one we restart one one of the
server's just stops an instance falls
out from underneath us so we retest all
of those yeah similarly failure
scenarios if you run on AWS things will
fail if you have a large fleet that will
fail often and so we look at those cases
where you know we decide we're running a
broker and we detach an EBS volume does
the Khafre cluster survive that we
looked at maximum packing density again
this is kind of a function of partitions
mainly but can we fit 100 tenants can we
fit 500 tenants whatever those look like
what is it how does it perform what are
the implications are failing over that
kind of stuff and bugs bugs was kind of
a painful one we did encounter bugs
obviously Kafka is somewhat immature it
has a crazy development cycle is really
actively being developed all the time so
I'll cover some some of those issues but
one thing which we we are I've done
pretty quickly and I mentioned
automation is kind of our thing
is that we want to automate testing and
so we developed an internal tool that
developed that leverages the internal
Hiroki api's and basically simulates
users and so it stands up a cluster an
empty cluster it creates 50 users and
then it creates a
user and a consumer or many producers
and consumers for these simulated users
and we can actually define profiles for
each user and say we want 10% of our
users to send very small amounts of
traffic we want 20% of them to send very
large messages but at a very slow speed
and then we want the rest of them to do
like some random distribution of data
and so we can actually script this and
it's reproducible so we release a new
version we run a new version of Kafka we
maybe tune the LS a little bit and we
say alright go in and hammer this
cluster and so it'll provision all the
users it will push all this data through
and then we actually monitor it and look
through the logs and say okay you know
this worked pretty well or we noticed
that when we did a rolling restart at
this point it struggled it took too long
to come up so yeah we also made
everything including our testing in this
case yeah so that was pretty cool but we
found a bug while testing Kafka
multi-tenant specifically it effects the
the way the code is enforced it's Kafka
for 725
you can look it up we discover this
while testing we noticed that we'd run a
test and in this particular set of tests
our test was what happens if we set
quotas to one megabyte and then
customers completely ignore it and they
start writing at ten megabytes what
happens and so kotas looked like they
were being enforced and then suddenly
one of the brokers would go down and
then all the other brokers would go down
and we're confused like what is going on
why is this happening and so we dug into
a little bit deeper and we found that
there's a memory leak and so the way
quotas are enforced is as I mentioned
it's delayed by the way they they slow
you down is by holding onto the response
so they don't act your response until
it's ready for to do so which would meet
your quotas but essentially what that
meant was they were holding on to a
reference of that message so you kept
sending me data and I just keep holding
on to more and more references to these
messages that you sent and so a memory
would go through the roof
JVM would sort of kill it because he ran
out of memory and the broker would go
down and then all of your traffic would
shift to the other brokers and they
would do the same thing and so you get
this cascading failure pretty quick
so we found that we contributed a PR and
it was accepted and fixed in zero 10.1
Darwin so yeah we were pretty active in
in testing new releases for Kefka that's
something we do we always provide
feedback on the mailing lists you may
have seen us yeah ultime ssin it's
totally our thing like I mentioned we're
a pretty small team and we manage
millions of databases so we have to
ultimately it does a lot in terms of
maintaining these clusters in terms of
like leader election and failover and
that kind of stuff but it doesn't do
everything it has no awareness of like
underlying instances so as I mentioned
if you're on AWS instances will fail and
if you're on a fleet big enough they
will fail a lot so our our mantra i
guess is to automate everything we
necessarily have to automate as much as
possible I semi jokingly believe that my
job is to automate myself out of a job
and so if I do a really really good job
then I will be useless and things will
just run themselves so what we do in
terms of automation is we have a lot of
tools for cluster resizing for replacing
nodes so the the automation itself looks
at the cluster and says my my plan says
I should have eight brokers so if I
don't have eight I should resize to get
eight and so we can literally go into
the AWS console out-of-band and start
deleting instances our automation will
go uh there's something all right let me
bring up another node and it'll start
filling them out storage expansion is
something I mentioned earlier as you
write more data to Kafka we detect oh
you're at 80% of your storage let's
expand that so we'll keep expanding it
as much as you you need essentially
until you've some other part of
monitoring says hang on you've exceeded
your limit by too much so we're gonna
we're going to do something about that
we actually ultimate version upgrades so
although you as a customer on a
multi-tenant plan can't upgrade yourself
we automate the upgrades for the entire
cluster so it's not possible for us to
manually go in and start messing around
with hundreds of clusters or thousands
of clusters
so we basically say okay now we're gonna
upgrade all of the kefka's to 2.1 and it
ultimately does it restarts I put a star
because it is very surprising how
effective a restart is there is the joke
of have you tried turning off and on
again that works really really well
actually
90% of our pages are handled
automatically by automation and the vast
majority of automation is to restart a
thing it could be restart the service it
could be restart the instance but yeah
turns out turning it off and on again
tends to work really really well
disproportionately well there is always
more stuff that we can automate we
really really ultimate everything our
team is really really small so yeah we
automate as much as possible my
colleague Tom Craver it has a talk about
running hundreds of Khafre clusters
where the team is 5 on how they
recommend you take a look at it he goes
into much more detail about our
automation I'm almost done but some of
the limitations these are the
unfortunate side effects of being able
to provide what we do yeah we don't
allow we don't allow the admin API we
don't we forced explicit topic creation
explicit customer group consumer group
creation those you keep racks us thank
you very much I will be taking office
hours somewhere nearby and if you want
to talk to me more please do so thank
you very much
so when you say you do a lot of testing
do you test with enable the encryption
on the fly so basically is a from client
to broker you encrypt the data it was
how much performance a hit you see when
you do the encryption so by default all
of our multi-tenant plans require SSL
encryption so there is like no way for
you not to use it on multi-tenant we do
see a performance hit but typically it's
like a CPU performance hit and almost a
hundred percent of our clusters are IO
bound and so practical implications are
pretty small the CPU doesn't run hot but
you're testing the limits of IO on the
volumes do you set up any schema
registry - well it ate those produce
input data unfortunately a schema
registry is a confluent product and so
we are not allowed to run a managed
schema registry for you but you can do
play it yourself
[Music]